Hi, we've got about two hours right now.
Let me check one
All right. So, here's the plan for right
now. Uh, we are going to get as far as
we possibly can on this code cleanup for
the new prioritized experience replay
implementation. And that's it for today.
That's the only plan. And tomorrow we
will continue and hopefully finish or
roughly finish said clean up.
trying to remember where we left off. So
where I can start with this
reuse? I wonder if there's a way to see
sample reuse.
We could technically
add a log variable.
I would like to be able to have some
stats about prioritization.
I can't think of a better way of doing
this at the moment than
um logging reuse directly. Maybe what we
do is we log it and then we decide
whether it's a useful metric,
idx. So we do data f uses of idx plus
equals
1. That's
fine. And then I think we have to zero
some stuff out.
So mean and log
data is
Okay, so this now
runs. Should still
train. And uh we do have
to log on Neptune to see this because I
didn't hook it
up. But then we should be able to see
the priority buffer usage. And we may or
may not keep this stat.
32. Uh, I don't think that makes any
sense, does it?
it? You J up
here. So you need to do this outside of
the
loop. It's kind of interesting that that
does
anything. But anyways, we'll just move
this
something. Wait, isn't this still
wrong? No, this is
good. All right, so
0.5 max of
22. That looks better,
right? Let's redo this with logging and
see if this is the expected
result. This 32 doesn't make any
sense. Oh, you know what? It probably
got accumulated over all the batches or
This is Is this still
printing or is it stuck
Okay, so this does worse than the bug
version. It's always the
favorite. Let me think about what it did
when I had it up here.
So when I had it up
there, it would take the
top the top end
Well, hang on. It shouldn't even be
using that buffer at all. Right.
happened. We definitely had it working a
second ago.
16k. Ah, okay. So, the last ones are
empty.
So you see the advantages are empty
here, right? The last advantages are
384. That is a million batch
size which is correct. Actually that is
So I guess what we want to
do go
here. That's not impossible index,
right? 8192 is the biggest index.
anything? I think this just upweights
the uh the probability of getting a top
sample.
See if this
trains and then we'll do top K instead
of sampling.
this. So we'll go to
sample. So instead of
knows. Okay, so this is a
solve. Now, let's see what happens with
top K instead.
right. Okay. So that's crazy. So top K
is very different from a
values. Oh, well, this means you're only
going to train on
these, right?
because I'm not actually computing this
correctly.
Okay, let's uh let's do some updates to
this
then. So the trick
here the values need to get recomputed,
right?
All the values need to get recmputed
actually. Well, that's a problem. How do
we recmp compute all the values?
We can definitely recmp compute the
um we can definitely
recomputee the values of the ones that
we
I guess we have to return indices,
right?
here.
Experience values.
So, that's not
good. We uh we don't want it to flatten.
Okay, that's slightly
annoying. Well, we're going to punt on
this for
I guess it tries to um do some weird
stuff with this.
where
this
faster. how long it takes to learn the
full
thing. Adding mask after first neuronet
got me 550 to to 675. Not
bad. Not
bad. Still funny that the other one is
so much faster.
That could just be the
um I mean neural nets don't like to do
tiny matrix
multiplies. Neural nets I mean graphics
cards don't like to do tiny matrix
multiplies. Yeah. Holy hell. This is
like immediately better, isn't
it? Turns out when you implement the
algorithm correctly, it does better.
What are you up to? I'm implementing uh
prioritized experience replay for PO.
uses. So it's deciding to use some
samples here like 70
times. Mean usage should always be 0.5,
right? Oh no, wait.
32. All right. So, this is scaled weird.
So, we'll have to check this
usage. Now, we see whether with this
change top K uh let's see if top K still
breaks
it. We would suspect that top K should
no longer break it.
much better than before. Not learning
anywhere as quickly as the other one,
though.
Interesting. I wonder why that learned
so slowly.
It's not like it isn't
working. It is. It's
just The updates are stable, too. It's
just really slow.
Well, I guess we keep the sampled
version for
now. But uh this is not where it should
be implemented either.
least? Like can I move
this to where it's supposed to be over
here or does this still break it?
least unless it gets stuck. It looks
like that at least fixed it from uh it
fixed that issue.
and it'll perform very
similarly.
Cool. So, that fixes it.
mean uses is
32. Yes, that that makes
sense. Wait,
32? That doesn't make sense.
these. It's very low. That doesn't make
sense.
0.5. I think I asked this before, but
for
multiprocessing, what
conditions would I like to use eight
workers, 8 M's and just instead of just
two and
two? Eight workers, eight M instead of
just two and two.
uh when you're hard bottlenecked by the
end. So at you'll have to use a larger
batch size to do that because to get the
same the same roll out length you need
to take more steps since you have more
ends. But uh going from uh two cores,
two workers was
it eight workers and two MS? Yeah, going
from two cores to eight cores. That goes
from single buffered up to 8x buffered,
which you pretty much never 8x buffer.
Um, at most you like quad buffer. So, it
wouldn't be like eight workers, 8 Most
likely, unless you have M batch size of
two.
Yeah, the numbers are a little off
there, Spencer, but it's you're
increasing the amount of buffering,
which decreases end of
overhead. You maybe think about that
when your M is slow and you can't speed
it
up, man.
[Music]
Oh, okay. I see. So, at most a sample
gets reused like six
times is what this is telling
me. Eight times, nine times, depends on
the
run. Cool.
And uh we can actually comment this
portion as
well. And then we'll see how it does
without
uh without the experience buffer.
better? It's kind of
funny. It is possible for it to just do
better. Yep.
Now we can adjust that as well. That
could just be too much off policy data.
Okay. So now this is a substantially
smaller
buffer. I think this still might be
slower.
That's still slightly
slower. What's like the per run variance
look like on these though? I
wonder. Is it just get
lucky or is it pretty consistent?
This does
worse. Okay.
You would think having a very small
replay buffer would do something
All right, that's not bad. It's still
slightly below, but this is
reasonable. And then we can sweep this,
right? We can definitely sweep this.
I guess we can compare it to random
sample,
Oh, wait. This
is Yeah. One and two advantages that
that's
correct. Wouldn't it be funny if this
ends up being better?
Okay. On par with uh
prioritized. It's kind of
funny. So, lots of different sampling
schemes to try. Obviously, we're not
going to conduct all our experiments on
breakout. That would be incredibly
stupid and limited.
Um, we do want to get this to a point
where we can start running those real
experiments though.
31. One
map. What about
GPU. Oh, well that's obviously going to
happen.
end. That's
unfortunate. So, it happened with more
maps. I just like screw that
up. Oh, I broke something with the M.
That's really weird.
Are there any other MS I can think of
where this would help a lot? I think
this is kind of the one, isn't
well. Well, I think that that's the
obvious end to try this on. So, we're
not going to be able to do anything
until we fix
that. I could port it real quick.
But I don't think I want to do that
right
yet.
Okay, we'll do some other stuff in the
meantime.
That seems faster than before,
right? But uh the ops or whatever
doesn't optimize quite as
That's close to the original solve time
actually. Original optimized best solve
time. Why does this not show
up? Why did I not run Neptune?
way. Yeah, I didn't run Neptune. That's
fine. That
works. So, the only difference is now
epochs can technically be a fraction,
right? I could say run half an epoch and
that means that you uh you only touch
each sample half a time on average.
that. Okay, this overall is decent.
See if uh neural3
runs. It does run. It runs at half the
speed it used to run at though.
where prioritized experience could help
you though,
So, we have that. We can do that
overnight. I'm tempted to just cue that
right
slow? No, it just used all the freaking
disc space.
sucks. We have to figure out that bug
for
Yeah. I don't know why those files would
be so big.
difference. Been wanting to ask you what
you think about RLHF.
I mean, it's language model specific,
right? People are now doing like full
RL, not just
RHF. Well, not really full RL. They're
still kind of doing a very pale
limitation of
RL. The latest thing is multi-turn RL,
which literally means RL that's not just
a single time step.
like LML RL the results are going to be
very impressive just because they've
been doing zero actual RL before but
like they're really really doing a tiny
tiny fraction of what RL can do for
language just domain specific reward
model.
I like I don't really know much about
RLHF, but it from what I've seen it
looks like you're
establishing a borderline supervised
problem except you don't instead of
having the supervision you only have
like A is better than B or
whatever. I mean like the classic like
which is better response A or response
B, right? Like that's you can see how
that's a very very tiny fraction of what
we do with RL right with RL we have long
series of
interactions and you sporadically get
often a very sparse
reward right you can see how that's a
very different
setting if you could run like if you had
the data and the scale to run RHF or
anywhere near the number of samples we
do in in actual RL L, you just solve
everything instantly because you
basically have you don't quite have
supervised learning, but you have
something that's a lot denser than what
we usually have in RL.
That still seems big. I'm talking about
the setting where your reward model is
not a human
feedback. Well, you said R LHF, right?
It's our reinforcement learning from
human feedback.
talking about any base model and any
gener general reward
model over an arbitrary number of steps
then that's just what you think about RL
in general and I do that all
day like what specifically are you
asking
Wow. Starting from a base
model. Well, if the base model isn't
particularly large, like they did that
as a crucial part of OpenAI 5, there was
a whole bunch of net surgery stuff to
warm start the model so they could run
more experiments. So, you know, when
they eventually ran it from scratch, it
did just as well. If you mean as a
distinction, what about when you use a
larger model? Yeah, you're going to be
able to do do a lot of stuff. If you
have a pre-trained language and vision
model, it's going to know language and
vision. And you're also going to need
thousands and thousands of GPUs which I
don't have.
Right? Reward function is not learned
from the data. That is not a
thing. That's what happens in
RHF. Not as far as I'm aware. In RHF you
have human feedback, right?
The human feedback gives you the reward
signal. Like the classic example, right,
is you have two completion candidates.
Is A better than
B? Learned preference model from human
feedback.
That's just an approximation of that's
just a smooth interpolation of of the
actual training data you have for the
feedback
model. I don't think there's any hack
here that gets you like infinite
learning yet or
whatever. Like it's literally a
classifier. Yeah. But
that's that's just that's just a
supervised model then over over the data
set that you
have. I don't think that gives you
infinite scaling.
I'm actually kind of frankly surprised
that we haven't gotten infinite scaling
yet. It seems like it should be pretty
easy, but evidently
not like why can't I just take any
halfdecent coding model, right? Anything
that can really output anything at all.
I'm surprised RHF works.
I mean, it doesn't really work as well
as the full RL, you know, from some of
the recent
stuff, but I'm kind of surprised that
something like that hasn't gotten us
infinite scaling. Like, why can't I take
why can't I just take
GPT4 and say become a better
programmer and give it access to a
compiler or whatever and just let it
rip, right? Why can't I do that?
that. Don't they already try to do that?
I have no idea. I don't follow the
Frontier model stuff, right? My job is
to fix
RL. At least that's what I've made my
job.
There are thousands of people currently
attempting to make language models work.
There is one person actually trying to
fix RL right now.
Me. And the proof of that is if anybody
else were seriously trying, then I
wouldn't be able to make RL like a
thousand times faster in a year. Because
you have to be you really have to be
trolling for uh to be doing something at
like a thousandth of the speed that is
possible.
In some ways, it's generous for me to
say nobody's
trying.
Interesting distinctions. One, the
reward models learn from the
data. Okay. I don't think that the way
that that's done in RHF really matters
that you're learning reward model
process starts from a good base model.
Yeah, that
matters. I want to see this extended to
non- language task. I'm tired of
language man. Well, but this is the
thing, right? Your base model doesn't
really help you on unintuitive tasks
that aren't really heavily language or
vision grounded.
That's the
issue,
right? Like, think about it. What's a
based model do? A based model tells you
how language and vision work and
arguably somewhat how reasoning
works. But that doesn't help you that
much when you have a a new fancy
unintuitive
task. And you're paying the price of
running a gigantic model every time you
want to, you know, run a sample.
imagine one that learns crude physics
from sensor data.
you you would need a really fancy
tokenizer trained on a lot of different
types of sensor data to make that
useful.
Generally, look, language and vision are
the two easy ones, right? There are a
lot of images and videos and there's a
lot of text and they're in roughly the
same
format. It gets way harder when you go
outside of that. You know, people do
specific stuff, right? people are
training models on like uh was it 3D
modeling data? They're now like 3D model
generators or whatever. But like just
getting arbitrary sensor data and making
something useful with that, that's
really hard.
realizing that.
Yeah. The thing is if there's nothing to
be a foundation
of, then uh your model doesn't really do
anything. If it's not a foundation for
anything, you can't really do much,
Maybe I should make this work waves
only.
You said you don't think the reward
model being learned is
important. Partially the reason why LM
can reward hack so
easily. Well, I don't think it's
like I don't think it's massively useful
is all.
If you're learning like supervised
reward function from the data, I like I
doubt you're learning something
massively more
useful. Like you're probably not doing
anything that's more useful than just
asking the language model which one it
thinks is better, which is
like the point
anyways of what you're training it on.
It's a chicken and egg problem, I think.
I don't know.
is fundamentally chicken and egg too.
No, it
isn't. Our rewards come from the
environment. We're not asking the model
what it thinks the reward is. We're
giving it one. It's very explicit.
value function or policy from scratch.
The value function is informed by
rewards that you get from the
environment and
um the policy is going to initially get
random data. Yes, you have to initially
luck into getting a reward or you don't
learn
anything,
right? But it bootstraps from there. As
soon as you start learning, the policy
is no longer
random. So, it's not chicken and egg.
It's like random and egg or whatever.
There's a big difference though. That's
still way better than what you're doing
in
um that's still way better than like
assuming that RHF would infinitely
scale. This does infinitely scale,
right? RL does infinitely
scale. It just takes a lot of compute
and you have to get bigger and bigger
models and all of that. Need a lot of
samples, but it does infinitely scale.
exponentially badly in some cases, but
it does scale.
see the paper about thousand layer RL
policies. I don't know why everyone
cares about that thing so much. What's
the point?
like that doesn't make any sense to me.
Like why is Doesn't matter.
See, this increases performance 2 to 50x
if you do not care how long it takes and
you would only care about
samples and it doesn't work in like this
is only
self-supervised. I don't even know if
this is really novel to be
honest.
Like world model type stuff already
scales to 200 mil nets.
Yeah, I don't know if there's anything
useful from this actually at
all. I've had like four or five
different people site this paper to me
being excited and I don't know why.
what I screw
up from six days ago.
If you replace the go bur thousand
layers with just recurrent
depth aren in the depth
dimension.
Uh no it wouldn't. That's uh that's a
thing. I worked on that a while
ago. So that's a hyper
network. Um no not a hyper network. A
highway network. My bad.
That's a highway
network. And one of my actually my very
first
paper. My very first published paper was
this
one for current highway hyper networks.
Tiny little amount of
code. This is what qualified as as NIPS
research back in the day. It was soda
technically. Um, but the thing is you're
still you have a fixed parameter budget,
right? You can't just do infinitely as
well, infinitely good by applying those
same parameters over and over. You can
do better, but not infinitely good.
And I would expect that to be especially
uh the case with the smaller RL
networks. You'd be very limited.
There. Much better. That's a smaller
file.
Okay, that should fix the blow up
So you're looping like billions of
parameters there,
right? Um you're looping like a million
parameters in the RL case. You're very
limited by that
budget. Rediscovering
RNNs. That's literally what a hyper
network does. I mean not a hyper
network, a highway network does.
node just looping a layer. Yeah, that's
what a highway network does. It reuses
the same weights over and over
again. Uses tied weights. So you like
unroll, you just do the computation with
the same weights like eight times or
whatever. And that's an eight layer
highway
net. Pretty darn sure at least that was
what it was. It's been many
years. I checked that really easily
because I have the implementation.
Why did this have 150 stars? Are people
actually ever using
function? Yeah. You
see? Oh, wait. Am I wrong?
Yep, I'm wrong. These aren't
shared. Huh. I remembered these being
shared
weights. I guess these aren't tied
weights. Maybe I tried that
originally. Yeah, I would be reusing
this several times. My
bad. It's literally just this. If you
replace this logic with one cell instead
of having it be cell of L, it's like a
twoline change to this.
go. Here's our agent playing Breakout
very, very fast.
I mean, you're free to try it. And if
you want to try it in an RL context,
like Huffer is very
fast. It's like this for a reason. It's
so that we can try lots of
stuff. Kind of cool to see how well the
RL just works now. Look at that.
This should be a perfect uh perfect
score
breakout. Yeah, there you
go. All right. So, that should fix the
load problem as well.
I guess what we do is we just start the
line by line, right?
What's an environment you want to really
see solved? Neural
3. When we have Neural MMO 3 solved, if
we do it without a whole bunch of janky
[ __ ] probably puffer is ready to
just like solve a few hundred valuable
problems in industry.
Uh, Net Hack is probably AI complete and
it's easy on paper to run RL scale on it
because it's really fast, but there's
some janky stuff that prevents you from
running enough copies of it in parallel
to actually train fast on it. So, it's
actually kind of hard to like run that
at scale.
Somebody could go fix that and it would
be really cool though.
I also don't think that like your
average like your average person and
certain like certainly your average
person and definitely uh or maybe even
your average researcher isn't going to
appreciate how truly complex of a
problem that hack is. You can run
multiple instances of it on separate
processes. Yes. Now go try running like
4,000 instances of it on a machine and
getting training going at a million
steps per second.
That's where the difficulties come
in. I can run a 3 mil perram net on
neural MMO at like 500k steps per second
already.
What's the technical bottleneck for
scaling net hack? It's the fact that
it's um it uses globals in C. So
apparently it's actually really hard to
get multiple instance of it onto the
same process.
If you could just get like a thousand
instances of Net Hack on one process and
run those in a loop in C, like that
should be very
it. No, [ __ ] Rust. Rust is an awful
language. [ __ ]
that.
H. It's not C. It's just I think it's
just that it uses some weird globals and
stuff. If they weren't using weird
globals, it would be
fine. It's not the language. It's just
like the way it's written.
enjoyer. I have like no desire to ever
interact with that
language, which sucks because I know
like there are some good programmers in
that community, but it's just it's not
for
[Music]
me. How'd you learn about the globals
problem over drinks with one of the net
hack devs at
Nurups? Hold on my chat ears. God damn
it. You
know, it's just the opposite of
everything I like about programming,
right? I like [ __ ] that's like, you
know, really concise and simple and
doesn't get in your way. And Rust is
just like a big freaking bloated
language with a million ways to do
everything. It has very strong and very
dumb opinions about how you should write
everything. It's just not Let me just
enjoy my C. All right.
Let me just enjoy my
sea. Still writing Ms from scratch in C.
Yep. I haven't personally written No, I
did I did write one like a month or two
ago, two months agoish. I wrote the uh
the maze grid
enth and then of course all the
contributors were still writing
everything in
C. I'm telling you it's very
easy. C has just been very maligned.
It's like it's so incredibly incredibly
easy. It's really just a joy to write
code and especially for this like
specific stuff. It's great. And now that
we figured out how to get around Syon so
we don't even need Syon anymore. It's
like peak
perfect. It's like peak coding
experience.
It's a lot of setup code with this,
isn't
there? Barrier prevents scaling that
hack is a legacy code engineering. Yeah,
it's legacy code engineering.
I haven't even tried to like bother
messing with it frankly,
right? Um there's some other stuff you'd
have to do with Net Hack as well, which
has mostly been done to be fair. Like
for instance, uh somebody
has somebody has a thing that like
renders it or whatever each character
into a
pixel, which is kind of useful.
Um, you kind of just want the op space
to be
like width height numbum channels if you
can. And there's some stuff that's a
little tricky with that. Like the bottom
line message you can't really do that
with, but that's mostly solvable. Like
you could definitely have something
pretty fast training on that
Actually Ryan who just defended his PhD
did a lot of work around that hack but
not as deep into the engineering as like
we do with puffer here right like I
don't think he went substantially into
the like the underlying sea or
anything
Sullivan he is uh naval in the
discord magikart profile guy. He's
Perfect. I was like looking at this
like, do we need
this? We don't need it.
this? I don't really think we need this
either to be honest with
you. The [ __ ] When did you add mu on?
I've been hard at work here, man. Does
it work for RL? Yes, it kicks ass. It
gave us a step change in
capabilities. It solved every single
environment in Puffer out of the box
with almost the same set of
hyperparameters except the really hard
ones. And so far, we've doubled soda on
neural MMO with it.
um Yeah, there's probably like an assert
that you need, right?
We'll keep doing checks
later. Does it still run?
That
works. Okay.
GPU
Nvid CPU NID.
fine. I don't know if there's a simpler
way of doing that.
I guess I could have the back end return
to a
slice. That might be
worse. I think we do this for now.
Let's see. Cuz it needs to have like
partial. Yeah, this needs like partial
buffer.
this. I don't know if I like
that. Yeah. See, I don't like that
because then it puts the index not in
the profile
miss. All right. So, if I leave that for
now, this is just the first pass after
all.
Don't ignore. We ignore these. We get
the reward
clamp state
you? This is just going to be on the
right
device. That's easy.
byD just for stored indices? It looks
like few other things.
not Yeah, we no longer use any of this
stuff. Let's update it.
and head out. Have a nice one. Have a
good one. See you around. I'll be back
first thing tomorrow as
well. Oh, hey YouTube
folks. We have a fair few people
watching me at 8:00 p.m. on a Tuesday.
Hi.
We're currently cleaning up our
implementation of prioritized experience
replay. Uh added on to
PO, mainly cleaning up the dev branch a
fair bit. Aiming towards a big release
soon and uh absolutely cannot release
with the code in this state. We've just
got way too many dev features that
aren't cleanly integrated or anything
Uh, that looks like we can clean some
stuff up here as
well. So,
and I think this is no
[Music]
longer no longer needed.
indices. Yeah. So these indices we
definitely need to handle masks on,
don't we?
When you store with N by ID, what do you
store
So I think you want to convert this to a
slice maybe,
right? This is already going to be a
slice
though when this comes
in. So if this is already a
slice, you should not have to do this.
slice. Yeah, you can't assign a slice.
Okay, that's
runs. Yeah, we're still good. Didn't
break
anything. Uh, reward should already be
on the right device.
Then this should already be on the right
device. Let's see if that
works. Yep, that does
work. Then what about this?
from? I thought that this is supposed to
be
um non
boolean. Oh, it is
boolean. The more you
again. Slice object not scriptable.
Lovely.
Not going to fiddle with that just
yet. If
instance, okay, this is two places that
I have
this. So, we have envid
EP
indices app
lengths. Um, is this no longer worth
using a
Oh, hey Linky.
Welcome. I'm going to bed pretty soon.
How's it
going? I assume that that's going to be
Star
Puffer. So, thanks for the
reminder, folks. If you want to help me
out for free, just star the repo.
Puffer.ai. Really helps us out a lot.
We're trying to hit 2K
stars, which is a really large amount
for an RL
project. Back to code.
How's progress on Xbuffer? It trains. It
works. Um, we really need to clean up
this
file. Honestly, the two biggest things
making it messy are E3B and diversity is
all you need,
though. How do your eyes not get tired
coding so late? It's only 8 something
p.m. here. I'm going to bed pretty
soon. I've also kind of been doing this
my whole life,
so you get used to
it. And not only am I staring at the
coding screen, I'm actually staring at
this big ring light up here as well.
deep diving tail scale box to see if I
can figure potential causes of the
latency on a few of the boxes. Uh, if
it's box zero and box four, it's because
I [ __ ] up the checkpointing logic and
they're currently both out of disk
space. So, I'm probably going to have to
figure out how to uh get into those and
delete some
crap. Possibly might have to figure out
just nuke the Docker container and
rebuild it.
That is why I originally wanted to have
the Docker container only be 95% of the
storage space so this couldn't
happen. Some kind of screen dimmer. Uh I
do have a screen dimmer
on. Actually, it should be getting a
little yellowower here. I don't know if
it shows on the stream or not.
index? Oh, there's no way to slice this
anymore, right? Yeah, I think I gave
that up with the current
implementation. Maybe a mistake. We'll
see. How's training perf? It's good so
far. I mean, I've been just training on
breakout, right? But we've got some good
breakout
runs. 1.5 million steps a
second. It's good so far.
Box two is showing derp server
timeouts. Pull the new puffer tanks and
rebuild
them. Accept my PR to it to limit usage.
Perfect. So, uh, lean key. Actually, we
probably need to really upgrade the
tanks because there's a dev branch of
puffer tank that has uh
new torch and stuff on it that is needed
for the dev
branch. Do you end up doing per sample
priority or just
trajectories? You cannot do per sample
priority with an LSTM. It doesn't work.
You have to do trajectory segments.
I came up with a reasonably clean way of
doing it though.
I don't see a per sample would be that
useful. It just doesn't work for
LSTMs. It's been tested to not break
2.0M down for an update to support
dev. Yeah, I think it's going to be like
Well, we definitely need to fix those
boxes, but literally all that happens is
we can remake the same containers and
those boxes will work.
Um, not even like rebuild the Docker.
Literally just like re, you know, wipe
the container and just make a new one.
Takes 5 seconds if we can actually get
into the
machines. Um, and then we'll apply yours
when we really redo all those boxes.
Speaking of which, the boxes are going
to get shipped pretty soon to uh the new
facility, which I think I put the
picture in the chat,
facility. That's pretty solid looking,
right? 40
outlets, Ethernet to all of them.
well. Yeah, we'll have to look at that.
There's a lot of stuff to look at over
the next couple weeks. Lot a lot of
stuff to look at.
We want to use slices whenever
possible, but then all this big indexing
here is not going to be able to be
sliced,
We should be able to have this be faster
though if we uh if there are some
special cases.
This isn't going to work without a
slice, is
it? If I just put this down here, this
breaks,
way. The fact that that's way longer is
scary.
index. There any way we can reduce some
of
better. The problem is that it would rep
it would result in very
long trajectories for slow
ends, which is a
problem. That's definitely a problem.
Yeah, the common use case here actually
we can simplify quite a bit the
difficult.
So if we're basically we're assuming we
always have a large number of parallel
M's and we're only getting one
trajectory segment per
end, then we do not need to keep track
of episode
indices. We can potentially very much
simplify episode lengths.
But the problem is like if we have if we
only store one trajectory segment
per environment and we have like Atari
with 24 environments then we're going to
have 24 giant trajectory
segments and that's not going to be good
for batching on the GPU. That'll be very
bad actually.
either.
Yeah. I think we have to leave it this
way for now.
I might think of a way to improve the
general case, but I think otherwise
we're going to get screwed by
this legacy code making our life hard
yet again.
Like really if I could really make this
very very simple if we just
assume like everything's a puff
around. I guess we have to deal with
this for
now. At least I at least we were able to
keep the J implementation simpler than I
thought it would
be. Okay,
so sample few different options we're
playing
with. Uh, we've got this stat that we're
playing with for
loss. We were going to play with like
torch compiling stuff like this,
I don't think we need this for
now. We can always get this back. We
don't need this for
now. Meaning
log. Yeah. So we can uh we can simplify
a little bit. This
We should actually see learning rate
being kind of cool on here,
right? Yeah, that's
the It doesn't do a very good job of it.
It's supposed to be cosign and kneeling.
I guess it doesn't have enough updates
or whatever.
analog. Okay. So, there's a little bit
of logging shenanigans.
That's not a big deal
cut. This file is getting to the point
where
like really the main things that are
making this a mess are just E3B and
diversity is all you need because these
are like two optional switches that we
don't know if we're going to be broadly
useful or not. So if neither of them are
useful, we just delete both of them from
the codebase. The codebase gets a lot
shorter. If any of either of them are
like really good and
impactful, then we uh you know, we just
keep them and we don't have the
switches.
And if they're like sometimes very
useful and sometimes dead weight, well
then we have to refactor and think about
how to like do this a little bit more
cleanly because this is a freaking mess.
But the rest of the code is getting to
be tolerable. We'll
tolerable. Get rid of some comments.
Again, we have all this in the old
version P3. Also never finished
May or may not keep
that. Let's see how we're using uh how
our train loop looks
though. Oh yeah, these
things. This should go at the end of
sample, shouldn't it?
I think I can just put this at the end
of
That also lets us get rid of these super
jank statements from
here. We have like this really
jank.
Yep. Okay, that's
better. Crystal frames.
entropy. Okay, so here is the real meat
of it, right? Comput generalized
advantage
estimation num samples
equals mini batch size over BPT
horizon. This can go up
You know what we can do? We can put this
in the
run. Yep. There you go. That's a little
better.
synchronize. Yeah, no longer need that.
We uh we fixed that in the
profiler. Not a big fan of um the way we
do this reshape either.
Honestly, I can't think of a way around
it, but I really don't like that we have
to
check whether the polic instance of an
LSTM
fine. Train miss. This is where we do
all the losses.
We're going to have to do a big
investigation into clipping with
PO.
Um, I'm actually suspecting the clipping
doesn't matter as much as one would
Okay, the rest of this is pretty clean.
What about the scalar
thing? I can do something like this,
right?
do after we're done with
it. You got your gradient
clipping. Doesn't Heavy ball have uh
gradient clipping built
in? Let me see.
Gradient
clipping string or
clipping gradient clipping function or
method. See heavy ball utils for
available options.
Yeah. Don't give me a 2000 line file for
available options, my
Let me just ask Lucas which of
these rainy clippings I should
use. See what is this adaptive? What's
actually do though?
This code's kind of silly. Know why it's
written this way, but it's kind of
silly. Well, we can leave our current
clipping for now.
line optimizer
step
otherwise data scaler step data
optimizer and data update. Okay.
interesting. Okay, we'll leave this for
now. But
Definitely we can simplify like some of
this accumulation logic. We've got it in
the losses. We've got it in a couple
places. So we know we can do
correct. I was just making sure we had
it indented.
And then we rec we rep prioritize
experience like
this plain. Varian needs
fixing. There's really not that much
more code
here. Get rid of these
updates without clogging the
dashboard. Know how to do that.
full. Did we ever call this?
I think it's just full
Fine. Now store functions relatively
short sample functions relatively store
short. It feels like we've made a dent
in this. We're down to 1161
lines. There's definitely quite a more
quite a bit more to shave off.
But that's good
progress and that's a good spot to call
it I think for today as
well is what we're going to do.
demo. That's nice. That's minus 100
lines with that
Looks like we have
reasonable reasonable stuff here. Yes.
overnight.
Okay. Uh it is slower somehow than
before and I don't know why but you know
that's for tomorrow. Cool. So lots of
good progress today. Uh I am planning on
being back first thing in the morning
pretty much and most of the week as
well most of the next several weeks. A
lot of work was going to happen over the
next bit. So uh if you want to follow
all of that, all my stuff's at
puffer.ai.
If you want to help me out for free,
just start star the GitHub repo. It's
all I ask. Really helps us out. We're
trying to hit 2K. If you want to get
involved in dev, whether you have RL
experience or
not, join the
Discord. If you want more RL content,
you can follow me on X where I post some
threads and some articles that you can't
find anywhere else. So, we do have a
blog here as
well. also restart box
7. Um, I don't think I can do that
remotely. Yeah, I don't
Okay, we're going to have to do some
stuff on all the boxes tomorrow because
we have several of them that are
misbehaving.
Um, okay. Well, thanks
folks. I will uh I'll be back probably
like first thing in the morning.